quand en commun le citron l'ail le
gingembre le parmesan et la noix de
muscade des raffine
ça peut être très agréable et ça peut
être très désagréable longiligne étroite
courte large étonnante la professeure
Pascal berrouti de l'idhq a testé 13 rap
entre 5 et 30 dollars en analysant la
texture des produits
quelques critères essentiels doivent
être considérés à l'achat de cette
ustensile de cuisine la poignée
confortable une zone qui soit
antidérapante pour être bien solide sur
notre poste de travail c'est sûr que les
lames c'est la partie la plus importante
d'une robe fine donc des petites lames
bien aiguisées bien sûr et aussi avec le
l'angle parfait on s'est demandé si on
considérait ça comme des rap fines pour
ma part non c'est trop gros c'est trop
gros les trous sont trop gros l'angle
aussi est trop importante je trouve que
l'intérêt de ces robes fines là pour moi
c'est d'abord et avant tout pour zester
ouais c'est définitivement la fonction
première le qu'on utilise le plus
souvent
pour faire un beau zeste quelques
recommandations de base s'imposent quand
on pèse trop fort sur la rampe il peut
vraiment y avoir des huiles essentielles
du citron qui se dégage ce qu'on veut
pas on veut que ça reste dans le zeste
pour aller dans notre préparation et
l'autre chose peut râper trop
profondément puis aller vraiment retirer
le disque qui est la partie blanche du
citron qui est plus amer qu'on veut pas
du tout avoir dans nos préparations des
fois on peut voir juste l'effet mouillés
que ça donne sur notre planche qu'on
n'aura pas du tout ici ça c'est le jour
et la nuit ça c'est votre préféré pour
vraiment pour le zeste pour presque tout
quand je regarde à côté de la micro
plante j'ai l'impression que ça pourrait
peut-être être le même fabricant
juste à l'effort j'en partage elle veut
pas il y a trop de résistance
en général c'est plus des moins bonne
performances qu'on va retenir c'est le
cas de la zwelling c'est l'aliment
peut-être le moins facile à manipuler
sur une robe fine comme ça alors son
petit compartiment qu'on peut venir
mettre la noix à l'intérieur par contre
je dois dire que c'est pas très facile à
manipuler
la noix balance beaucoup à l'intérieur
du sujet ça m'étonne bien
on peut très bien voir que la noix au
lieu d'être râpé je s’abîmer et juste
abîmée on a notre quantité de noix de
muscade qui est aussi assez grossière
tandis que la Oxo travaille comme un
charme il y a très peu de résistance à
glissent très bien j'ai pas peur de
perdre équilibre et de devenir me
rappeler les doigts on va la différence
pour le parmesan on cherche un résultat
fin et aérien mais préférez ont été
encore la micro plane et la joie du
président
qui a fait vraiment un beau résultat
donc le mouvement il est très fluide on
a une belle largeur aussi de l'âme là
qui fait que on n'a pas besoin de se
concentrer sur où on aura parce que
cette surface de travail là est beaucoup
plus intéressante
la très légère râpe Trudeau laisse notre
professeur perplexe en forçant avec le
fromage sans pas très stable
c'est très très étroit aussi
le mouvement il est pas très fluide
on aurait pas peut-être que ça pourrait
lâcher à la jonction des deux exactement
dommage parce que le résultat est quand
même intéressant
[Musique]
Ricardo offre deux modèles qui sont
quelques dollars près même prix une à
angle ouais c'est plus intéressant mais
j'ai trouvé que c'était plus facile dans
le maintien là un angle plus naturel
pour le poignet
on cherche un gingembre qui perd pas
trop son jus et surtout un gingembre qui
qui ne pue vraiment ses fibres
ça fait pas trop purée un petit peu un
peu un petit peu puis elle travaille
bien dépendamment des aliments mais je
dirais que somme tout est dans la
moyenne tout le temps lesquelles
perforeraient bien pour le gingembre
alors dans mon cas j'ai préféré la
cuisine pro et la micro plane ouais
encore une fois
pour avoir de l'ail très fin l'arabe
large choix du président est considéré à
nouveau
facile pas d'effort
puis ben on a très peu de résidus à cet
endroit-là et on a quelque chose de très
fin de l'autre côté je me trompe ou vous
l'aimez bien celle-là quand même j'aime
beaucoup son prix aussi 5 dollars c'est
la moins chère du Lot puis le effectuer
quand même du bon travail sur toutes les
aliments
[Musique]
qui dit l'arme dit coupa les étuis sont
donc un atout pour le rangement par
contre des lames à tranchant opposées
comme l'autre modèle choix du président
et la cuisine pro sont plus dangereuses
à manipuler surtout quand vient le temps
de les nettoyer on peut pas un seul
trait exactement avec un nettoyant linge
il y a des fibres qui restent c'est pas
du tout ce qu'on aime lesquels j'évite à
tout prix définitivement
je veux pas m'acharner mais il y a aucun
aliment qui a été vraiment agréable à
travailler dessus
et sans surprise la grande préférée à 23
dollars ça a été la micro plante pour
vrai
tout était vraiment agréable à faire
avec les résultats étaient présents pour
chaque aliment donc indénosables je
pense la microplane j'ai essayé mais non
[Musique]